hello friends i'm alana and what you're
about to watch is basically an
excerpt from a stream where i had a
bunch of people submit some of their
work to me so that i could sort of help
them if they wanted to get into games
media
um and people said that they found this
part of the stream really helpful so i
thought that i would also publish it on
youtube though it was exclusively a
twitch stream in this case
i also just quickly wanted to give the
context to anyone who doesn't know me
hi i'm alana i've been working in games
media for eight years
i studied journalism at university i
started out writing in magazines and
also on websites
i was then hired as a writer at ign um
and part of my job ended up being
editing people
i now work for funhouse and inside
gaming and i still do a lot of
editing in terms of both news writing
and feature writing at
inside gaming so this video is to
basically show you or anyone who might
be interested into getting into games
media or games journalism
what i would look for when editing
someone or what i look for when
i'm looking for a freelancer or someone
to write a feature of course not
everyone edits the same way not everyone
has the same requirements as me but
still thought it would be helpful
so enjoy all right
uh recently we learned take two's nba
should i do it in a news person voice
recently we learned take two's nba
2k21 due for release on september 4th
will cost an additional 10
for the playstation 5 and xbox series x
editions versus the ps4 and xbox one
versions
so you've done a good job of already not
doing the thing where people give me
their personal [ __ ] backstory but i
would say
this first sentence is a little bit too
long so all i would do is cut it here
so we're going to cut that there
recently without tattoos i would even go
how did we learn it how are we going to
source this um so a recent posting
on nba oh no it's take two's newsroom
yeah recent press release is gonna be
fine recent press release from
2k you get rid of the other website
source and you source 2k directly
is this something take2 is doing just
for nba 2k or is this a sign game prices
we'll be training up for the first time
in almost
15 years source question mark
um yeah this is literally exactly how i
write things uh
sorry how i edit things at work right so
this the starting sentence is always the
thing that i tend to edit the most from
anyone's work
which is um facts first
get your facts out as quickly as
possible and as concisely as possible
which is where did it come from
how do we find this information out what
is the thing um
you could actually take out and some
editors probably would the judo release
on september 4th i like that though
um and then we'll cost you 70 on
playstation as a series x done
that's it okay so that's that
um to
idg well because you sourced games
industry
you sourced games industry.biz who
sourced someone else
which you're not allowed to do as
reported by
games industry.biz
games industry dot biz
this would need a source but i would cut
it
should games go maybe we make that a new
paragraph then
this is a really good sentence um but
again
source what games and by who
uh current aaa titles yeah you're going
to need to be more specific with that i
have budgets up with
80 million at the time it takes to you
know
make things any cheaper you also need a
source on that these commentators often
like to remind us
prices haven't really kept up with
inflation
uh it's also worth noting that
um this is not valuable information to
an audience
so boom just
today keep it simple just today
this is also something that would
technically need to be sourced because
you are making
a very definitive statement
uh that i also don't know is necessarily
pro-corporation
um i mean it's not not but it also
isn't definitely from that angle right
on the flip side
why that means you can get rid of all
this
on the flip side consumer it's worth
considering that
a source
that's gonna need to be united states
specific
in the united states you listed
states hasn't increased since 2009
which affects not only minimum wage
workers but all these companies choosing
something
as well um that's also going to need a
source
what makes you think this because you
kind of can't write anything that is
just your own opinion unless you
literally say in my opinion or this is
how i feel
if that makes sense but you definitely
need a source for that
and then you need a source or i go
source
or expand to explain this further to
people who have never heard of this
concept like myself
as a foreigner i don't know what you're
talking about the prevalence
of microtransactions in the games
industry
has also changed
the way
change the what am i looking for um
earnings potential i guess kind of works
it's probably a bit too fancy but you
get my idea uh
earnings potential is not going to be a
thing that i am happy with but i'm going
to write it for the sake of it
um that's
too much of a big statement
games like question mark and question
mark and question mark
which have grossed
however much they have grossed
uh
no feature
feature new gun skins
and characters on top of a
60 dollar
the initial sixty dollars
source championing a retail price
increase also ignores downloadable
content
which has become segregation's
generation that complete editions of
games will also cost that's kind of
also a thing that you need to source
yeah i feel like you've done it in the
next sentence
but i would say which in some cases
has become so reduced generation that
complete editions of games will also
can can also cost
can will also can also cause [ __ ] off
also cost nearly twice as much as the
base
game at launch the completed 109 really
that's just fancy batman arkham knights
dlc was particularly infamous for this
source i would say
this was particularly
controversial
considering
many fans and critics alike
believed the game
so i hate the sentence i just wrote but
it's better to write something than to
write nothing
um you would also have to source this
source uh yeah don't like that sentence
but it's fine you get my point
like i always just gotta write the thing
and then figure it out later this i
would go
give me a list of games that launched
launched without um rather than saying
few hope
high profile games because that might
not be true or
put in the extra like hard work to give
me
like literally break that down spend
hours being like here are the top
selling games of the generation here are
the top ten
these ones include a dlc and these ones
don't um
that's where you push yourself to being
a more impressive journalist because
that's an easy sentence to write and
while you're not wrong
uh part of the work is is showing people
the information they won't look for
themselves
so that is probably what i would suggest
is give me the top 20
games of the generation and break down
by percentage which launched
with the oh no which had dlc dlc
which didn't and do the same for micro
transactions
um so that you are actually
you know providing information that a
lot of people won't generally look for
assassin's creed odyssey is one of my
favorite games of this generation but on
top of costing 110
for the full version ubisoft filled its
game it's in game style with costumes
weapons and armor for the player to buy
with real money
i'm totally cool with the sentence i
personally
again subjective would say uh give me
more
how did this game specifically uh
if i've never read anything you've
written before this sentence means
nothing to me right
well okay you kind of did do this here
i'm going to get rid of a lot of this is
what i think i'm going to do for this
particular editing puzzle
uh i received a few side quests is there
a this
like this is a thing that a lot of
writers would um tell me to [ __ ] off for
but i would say
is there some way we can measure this
can we time this can we see
exactly how long it takes versus a game
that you think does push this too far
eh eh eh again like i've had writers be
like no alana that's too much work i
won't do it and i'm like
that's fair don't worry about it it's a
strong stance
expresses a cowardly desire to ignore
the game's own design philosophy which
urges the player to go in their own
personal odyssey with their character
and travel making this
i think you're maybe a bit off track
here
um that is a separate feature so i would
delete it
and then i would say let's write
something else about this
uh let's play the publishers i'm making
about the rising cost of games it's
frustrating to hate because we see the
evidence again and again that games are
buying microtransactions by the drugs
um obviously source
where to evidence that though okay so he
had to find a way to tie this
paragraph to previous paragraph um
i love editing because i always look at
this [ __ ] like a puzzle you've listed a
bunch of different kinds
of micro transactions so that's what i'm
going to say
um no that would i guess also be a no
just at the end of this
entire paragraph any other
hang on i'm down um types of micro
transactions
we can list here question mark this plea
that so this also needs to be
sourced which publishes and when which
is why
they keep putting them in games i would
also try and source that
but you don't really need to like for
this
a sentence like this
i would reach out to someone for comment
i would reach out to
let me pull up basically like so i i
guess i need to beat romney a bunch for
this
um but basically like yeah so i have i
reached out to
michael pachta he told ign the problem
is that more people play the same games
longer they necessarily buy fewer games
and that's where the desire for more
revenue arises and
basically i would just reach out to
someone other than you for that opinion
like you're not wrong like i think that
that's right
but you could get an industry analyst to
give you more detail on that so i would
write like
can we get more detail
on how this works from a dev
or analyst or publisher basically
definitely for this if you're going to
talk about fighting games specifically
interview for sure comment
and games are costing more to make you
can't say that because there could be
someone saying that
you're not allowed that is illegal
that's also a very strong stance i'd get
rid of that entirely
okay um i would probably if we're
getting personal here
i find most insulting i think that's
okay this is what i
personally find so i don't write this
way but i have to again be like you
don't have to write
for me so this is what i personally find
most insulting if you establish that
it's your opinion
rising cost of games isn't going to get
rid of dlc
interview
can you ask a dev what they think about
this
i won't result in them hiring more
developers in the hopes of reducing
hours of crunch
source or say in my opinion
or probably etc
myself raising the cost of games merely
guarantees that i buy even fewer games
at full price than before there's no
point in taking risk on games
i might not enjoy when i'm spending all
very fair and again
you wrote for myself this is this is
great
with most gamers already waiting on
titles already waiting for titles
titles to go on sale
i would probably list an example of a
sale
a game that recently recently went on
sale
steam sale etc um because you need to
source
because you need to source that game is
actually
dude do this especially
when you say most so
yeah give me proof that most gamers do
that
if you can't find the proof yourself
interview no you did say why source
um that's pretty speculative it's
entirely possible more third-party
developers want it on this kind of
service choosing to receive a monthly
recurring revenue
do we have examples of profits from
either of these
services we do for the record that's
public information
after all they'll get almost all the
profit rather than a portion like with
physical games
that's not true that is just false um of
course this result a different set of
difficulties for them
because they'll no longer be com merely
in competition with one another but with
everyone in the streaming business like
hp2
this is a separate article so i'm
actually going to say
expand um i like that as you're
concluding
narrative i'm going to say expand on
this bit maybe another paragraph
um yeah that's fine just just talk about
that a little bit more
because it's just being the way it is is
one sentence is so off the cuff
so otherwise it would be get rid of it
the next console generation is going to
give us that answer
get rid of that your conclusion can be
streaming services are coming in it'll
change the landscape and we did it